So you.
He did write the book, dear reader on, uh, Kim Jong IL. Yeah. Dear reader.
The unauthorized autobiography of Kim Jong-il. Yeah.
So that's the previous leader of North Korea, correct?
Current one is the UN jargon. No, no creativity on the naming.
Well, no, this is intentional because it's a throwback to, um,
the dad.
So there's been only three leaders in North Korea.
So we've talked about the history of Hitler and Stalin and like these,
I think it's important to understand that the history of those kinds of humans
there's the history of North Korea is not well written about or understood,
which is why your book is exceptionally powerful and important.
So maybe in a big, broad way,
can you say, who was,
who is Kim Jong IL as a,
as a man, as a leader,
as a historical figure that we should understand and why should we understand
them?
So I wrote dear reader by going to North Korea and getting all their
propaganda, which is translated to several languages.
Cause they're going to see it as everyone on earth is interested in them and
wants to narrow their ideology.
And he died in 2011, 2011. And you wrote the book in 2012.
Uh, I w I went there in 2012. I wrote the book came out in 2014.
So Kim Jong-il is, um, donut and intellect,
North Korea version of Forrest Gump in that when they write their history,
whenever something appeared happens, he's there. Uh,
and by telling his life stories in the first person he's telling the history of
North Korea. So I wanted to write the kind of book where in one book,
and it's the kind of reading you can do in the beach or the bathroom.
You're going to get the entire history and know everything you need to know
about North Korea and one accessible outlet. And it's,
it's what people don't appreciate about North Korea. The several things,
how bad it is, and this didn't happen overnight.
This was very systemic that what this family did to that country,
where piece by piece, they did everything in their power to hermetically,
seal it from the rest of the world, ramp up the oppression, uh,
keep any information from coming in. And, you know,
they're very creative and innovative in their
style of, uh, manipulation and control. Um,
so there is a farcical element. Let me give you an example.
So people in the West kind of get it wrong. They're talking about, Oh,
they talk about when Kim Jong-il played golf for the first time,
he gets 17 holes in one,
there's this one story about Kim Jong-il shrinking time.
And this is a story and it sounds supernatural, but it's not.
So Kim Jong-il is that a conference,
the dear leader and someone is giving a talk.
And while that person is giving a talk,
Kim Jong-il is taking notes and working on what was work.
And he has an aide who keeps interrupting him with questions and the speaker
keeps stopping. And Kim Jong-il says, why are you stopping? He goes,
I see you're doing some other things. And it goes, no, no, he can,
I can do all these things at once. Everyone was shocked. And they said,
this is why Kim Jong-il looks at time, not like a plane,
but like a cube. And he can shrink time. And my friend goes,
do they mean multitasking? And yes,
Kim Jong-il is the only person in North Korea. Who's capable of multitasking.
So in order to elevate him,
they basically make everyone else in North Korea,
completely incompetent. Um,
and that has a purpose because should the leader go away?
This country is going to collapse overnight. So this,
they laugh in the West about all these newspapers, show him, you know,
at the factory. And he's at the fish hatchery at the paper plant.
They say the difference in North Korea is that the leader goes among the people
and does what he called field guidance. So he will go in that farm and be like,
this is what you need to do. And he'll go here. And he's so smart.
He's good at everything. And thanks to him for sharing his wisdom with us.
And he's not removed from the people like in every other country.
Why does that seem to go wrong with humans?
Do you think that this kind of the structure where there's this one,
figure the authoritarian, this,
the totalitarian structure where there's one figure,
that's a source of comfort.
Kim Jong IL is not good at farming.
Kim Jong-il is not good at the machinery.
It's all a complete lie or the things he'll point out will be things that are
completely obvious. So here's another example they use, uh, in North Korea,
they have something called the tower that you should idea, which is an obelisk,
which looks like the Washington monument,
but it's completely different because it's got this like plastic torch at the
top. And they talk about in the propaganda,
how all the architects got together. And they said,
Oh,
we should make this the second tallest stone obelisk in the world.
And Kim Jong-il says, no, let's make it the tallest. They're like, Oh,
we never thought of this before. And the way it's presented as it. And like,
he's the first person to think of this.
Like these architects that having a brainstorming session.
That's how did you idea? They're like, all right,
we gotta do something innovative to put North Korea on the map. What can we do?
How about second biggest piece going to go for this? And then he's like, Oh,
we never thought of this. It's it's it's. So,
because I presented at face value, people sometimes say the book's a satire.
It's not a satire. I downplayed all this stuff. It's a far Susan.
Another example, North Korea is very big.
And I think Russia is to some extent too, on amusement parks.
Funfairs they call them the British style because this is the chance for the
people told to get together. And there was this amusement park.
It's almost like South park,
the Cartman where there's all these rides and Kim Jong-il is
like,
I'm not gonna let any elderly or take these rides
until I put myself in danger and ride them
myself. And they go, but dear leader, it's drizzling. And he goes, Nope,
I have to make sure these rides are going to be safe for everyone.
Even during the light rain to go well, can we go on these rides with you? No,
no, no. The courageous one.
And he's riding all the rides and they're standing there crying at his courage,
but that's what's and you asked all the things and when power it's like, listen,
I'm quite confident that those FunFair engineers are in a position to
ride modest mouse reference called by themselves and be like, yeah, okay.
This is good for the kids. Uh, although to be fair,
some of those amusement parks are pretty rusty and dangerous, but that, that,
that kind of.
Propaganda, I guess what, I'm not playing a devil's advocate. It's like,
it's, it's comforting and it's useful,
but it does seem that that naturally leads to an
abuse of power.
How can it be used correctly?
No one person has the intellect or the mind to understand the
entirety of an economy, let alone every individual field of interest.
Well, for example,
you can have an artificial intelligence system that understands the,
the entirety of it.
I think just complete shame, the mask slip.
So you could have an artificial intelligence system.
Uh, but like the question is can that
mean like the, the, the human version of that is like,
you can hire a lot of experts, right? You can be an extremely good manager.
Yeah. Since everything's dynamic, it's not going to,
they're not going to have the data to kind of manage it. Well.
It seems that there's a, like what George Washington allegedly did.
It seems like most humans are not able to fire themselves.
You're you're not able to like, yeah, you're right.
I'll tell you to be a check in your own power, but that's not. If I was like,
uh, if I was creating a human is like,
that's not an obvious bug of the system that we would
not be able to fire ourselves due to, uh,
to know when we have, I mean, it seems like that's something you have to know,
always like that's something I often wonder is like, am I wrong about this?
Well, this is what we talked about earlier.
What are the safety valves to make sure that okay,
if I am incorrect or my knowledge is finite Plato's cave kind of thing.
What mechanisms are in place that my mistake we're limited information.
Isn't going to have deleterious consequences. I,
North Korea does not really have that. And as a result,
they had polio in the nineties.